>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC
>> Jonathan Loar: All
right, hello, everybody,
welcome to today's lecture.
I want to thank everyone
for coming out.
My name is Jonathan Loar,
and I'm the South Asian
reference librarian here
in the Asian Division of
the Library of Congress.
And I just wanted to thank
everybody for coming out.
What we have is a fantastic
lecture today, "The Sikh Legacy
in Pakistan", by
author Amardeep Singh.
Today's talk is presented by the
Asian Division of the Library
of Congress, and the
National Sikh Campaign.
At the outset I'd like
to first extend my thanks
to Dr. Rajwant Singh of
the National Sikh Campaign,
for putting me in touch with
Amardeep, and for also helping
to promote today's event.
Please be advised that today's
program will be recorded,
and later released as a webcast.
So please turn off or
silence your mobile phones
and other devices.
Also, please be advised that any
questions you may ask at the end
of the program will be
recorded, and that the act
of asking the question
constitutes permission for us
to record and broadcast
later as a webcast.
As a reminder, there
will be time
for questions after the talk.
And we ask that you ask,
you know, short questions
about topics relevant
to the presentation,
as opposed to extended comments.
Before we get started, I'd
like to invite Dr. Qi Qiu,
the Asian Division's head
of Scholarly Services just
to say a few words
about the Asian Division
and the Asian Reading Room
at the Library of Congress.
Dr. Qiu.
>> Dr. Qi Qiu: Thank
you, Jonathan.
On behalf of the Asian Division,
welcome to this afternoon's
event.
So if you are familiar with
the Library of Congress
or its Asian collections, you
probably will know that here
at the Library, the Asian
Division operat, both physical
and digital collections
in Asian languages,
and get research assistance
from our subject specialists.
The Asian Division was formerly
founded in 1928 as the Division
of Chinese Literature.
So this year actually
marks the 90th anniversary
of the Asian Division.
Even though it was named the
"Division of Chinese Literature"
when it was founded, it
started collecting Chinese
and Japanese materials,
and received Mongolian
and Tibetan materials as gifts
in the late 19th century.
So from the earliest,
the gift of presentation
to the United States by
the emperor of China,
the collections of the
Asian Division have grown
to represent one of the most
comprehensive collections
of the Asian languages
in the world.
That is more than four
million physical items.
So these items are in
more than 130 languages,
and include most subject fields,
covering in the area ranging
from the South Asian
subcontinent,
to Southeast Asia, to East Asia.
So in the next few minutes,
Dr. Loar will give a more
detailed introduction
of our South Asian collections.
So users can access
our collections
at the Asian Reading
Room, which is located
in the Thomas Jefferson Building
across the Independence Avenue
on the fourth floor, room 150.
So our reading room opens Monday
to Friday from 8:30 to 5:00 p.m.
So anyone who is 16
years or older can come
to use the Library
reading rooms.
All you need to do
is bring a photo ID
and get a reader
registration card.
The registration card location
is also on the first floor
of the Jefferson Building.
And of course, it's
always a good idea
to consult Library catalog
and Asian Reading Room website
before you come to the Library
so that you can identify
the materials
that you will be looking
at, and make better use
of your time at the Library.
So in addition to general books,
we also have special collections
and rare books in many Asian
languages, and users need
to make appointments
with our librarians
to use the rare items.
And you can request
appointments, request materials,
and send research questions on
the Asian Reading Room website
at the link marked "ask
librarian" [phonetic].
So "ask a librarian"
is an important phrase
for you to remember.
And also, we subscribe to
many electronic resources
in Asian studies, and users
can access them anywhere
in the Library's campus.
All this information
will be included
in the brochure available here.
And we hope that it will not be
your last trip to the Library
of Congress, and we
hope to see you again
in our reading room
at the Library.
Thank you.
[Applause]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Jonathan Loar:
Thank you, Dr. Qiu.
And in similar fashion, I'd
like to give you the briefest
of brief overviews of the
South Asian collection
that we have here at
the Library of Congress.
The South Asian collection,
of course, contains materials
from Ba, and over 68,000
titles on microphage.
We have substantial holdings in
many languages, including Hindi,
Urdu, Bengali, Tamil, Gugurati
[phonetic], Punjabi, Telagus,
Indian, Nepali, Rajistani
[phonetic], and many more.
For example, we have about
13,000 books on Punjabi alone.
Much of the acquisition comes
from our two overseas offices,
one in New Delhi, established
in 1962, and the other
in Islamabad, established
in 1965.
Overall, the South Asian
collection provides broad
research coverage in most
fields and disciplines,
especially vernacular languages
and literature, religion,
philosophy, politics,
history, and sociology.
The collection is also
very strong with regard
to newspapers, journals,
and government publications
from South Asia.
All of these materials -- and
you'll see some examples here
in the slide behind me, all
of these materials are just
like today's lecture, free
and open to the public.
To request materials
from our collections,
all you need is your
reader registration card.
But in the meantime, you
can browse our collections
with the online catalog
at catalog.loc.gov
and you can even limit your
search by langBuilding,
room 150, where you can
access all of our materials
in these South Asian languages.
You can learn more about
the South Asian collection
on the website of the
Asian Reading Room,
and we also invite you
to check out the Library
of Congress Four Corners
of the World blog,
and International
Collections Facebook page,
both of which contain
information on special items
in our collections, as well
as info on upcoming events
and lectures, like
today's lecture.
Now I'd like to invite
Dr. Rajwant Singh
to say a few words, and to
introduce today's speaker.
Dr. Singh is cofounder of
the National Sikh Campaign,
president of Eco
Sikh, and secretary
of the Guru Gobind Singh
Foundation in Rockville,
Maryland, to name only a few
of the organizations
in which he serves.
Please welcome Dr.
Rajwant Singh.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Dr. Rajwant Singh: Thank you,
Jonathan, for this warm welcome.
And we are extremely thrilled
and excited to be here,
and are trying to
take the advantage
of Amardeep's being
here and enlightening us
about this wonderful and
very valuable treasure
that our community has, but
still not yet discovered.
So we are very much thankful
to the Library of Congress here
and the Asian Division.
And I had no knowledge that
you have four million books
on ancient languages, and
130 different languages
from the Asian region.
And this is something which we
will want our kids and children
of our community
to be exposed to,
and hopefully will develop
some working relationship
with the Asian Division here.
And we are also very
delighted to hear
that there's 30,000
Punjabi books,
which is an amazing collection
that we should be
taking advantage of.
And so as we are moving
towards the 550th anniversary
of the birth of Gurnanik
[phonetic] next year,
hopefully we'll be planning some
events with the Asian Division,
hopefully in the next year.
And so I want to thank, once
again, Jonathan for working hard
and really putting
this thing together.
And hopefully, we will
continue this relationship.
And I want to thank the chief
of the Asian Division, Dr. Shao,
for being here and, you know,
opening the doors of the Library
for our community,
and for this lecture.
And Amardeep has really done
an amazing job of exposing all
of us to something
that we had no idea.
And in his lecture, he will
definitely give us a glimpse
of the immense treasure that the
community has left in Pakistan
over 70 years, and really
focused on restoring some
of the most important religious
shrines, but for Amardeep
to really open up -- open
our eyes to the legacy
of the Sikh empire
[inaudible] and all the warriors
and the wonderful relationships
that these warriors,
and these kings, and the
administrators had built
with the local population
in Pakistan
and the northwest front.
So that is -- really has excited
the community throughout the
world, and especially
the Washington area.
We have had two opportunities
for him to speak
at different [inaudible], and
there are a lot of young people
who are becoming interested
in knowing more about this.
And our hope is that from this
phase, we go to the next phase
of really preserving these
monuments, and this work of art
and work of history that
we can keep this alive
for coming generations.
So Amardeep has -- was born
in Goa Port [phonetic],
India and has lived in India,
Hong Kong, and Singapore,
and has been educated
at the Dunes School.
And he pursued his electronics
engineering at Manipal Institute
of Technology, and masters
in business administration
at the University of Chicago.
And while he was working for
American Express, certainly,
he developed this
passion, which he has --
you know, he had the
passion in photography,
but now from the last
three and a half years,
he has dedicated his
life to really working
on the Sikh legacy in Pakistan.
And he's written these
two wonderful books.
And those of who have not yet
gotten them, we will be able
to acquire them for you.
Please give your name or
contact information to myself.
We can get them available
to you.
So we really want to -- on
behalf of the community,
we want to thank Amardeep for
is wonderful wife is with us.
Would you please stand
up and be recognized?
Please welcome her.
[Applause] Amardeep would not
have accomplished what he has
done in the last three or
four years without the support
of his wonderful wife.
So Amardeep, once
again, thank you so much.
And on behalf of the
community, we welcome you.
Please, we are here
to listen to you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Dr. Amardeep Singh: Thank
you to the Asian Division
of the Library of Congress, and
to the National Sikh Campaign
for having created this platform
to allow me to share some
of the insights from my two
books, the one which is --
you're seeing on the screen,
which is the first book
on your right-hand
side of the screen,
which is "The Lost Heritage of
the Sikh Legacy in Pakistan,"
and the second book, which is
called "The Quest Continues:
Lost Heritage of the
Sikh Legacy in Pakistan".
Both these books
are a culmination --
in the short way I can say of a
journey that I started in 2014
when I stepped into
Pakistan for the first time.
And it's taken me about
three and a half years
to document the remnants,
both tangible and intangible,
across Pakistan in 126
cities and villages.
But actually, in true sense,
I don't think this
would have been possible
in such a short span of time had
I not unknowingly been preparing
myself for the day the divine
would choose me to step
into the country and himself
start showing me the places
through a strange energy
that was engulfing me.
And connecting me to people
which allowed me to kind
of experience what I have
experienced and written
and chosen to write
in these two books.
Because I think these books
are going to be a valuable work
for posterity, because
in seven decades,
we've not had another
publication as I see,
and that's the reason why I
decided when I went to Pakistan
that I need to dedicate
my few years of my life
into documenting this what I had
seen, because there are people
who have deep pockets, they
can serve through wealth.
There are people who
can serve through time.
And I choose to serve
through my time
and my own research
that I've done.
So in many ways, the lot of
opportunities that you give
up when you take up such
works, it's a career
that I've sacrificed, but
I'm glad that I've done it
because it's a part that has
not been credited [phonetic]
on by anyone for seven decades.
And a lot of people ask me how
challenging this work has been,
and I want to start with
that itself, that, you know,
challenges are abound.
Multitudes of challenges
have come on my way.
But the sense is that works
like these if they were easy,
then theoretically you
should be having many,
many more publications like
these available in the market.
So if you take a monument
like Taj Mahal, I mean,
there are more than
10,000 books available.
So why is it that
for the Sikh legacy
in Pakistan there are
no more books available?
And therein lies the
answer to the question
as to how challenging it is.
It is not a bed of roses,
but yet some strange energy
has created the path for me.
And for this, I want to
thank the people of Pakistan,
because they embraced me.
I was simply a man with
a passionate desire
to understand something
about our past, our roots.
But if they wouldn't have
embraced me, unknown people,
the work would not
have happened.
I also want to thank
the Pakistan government.
We were hoping someone from the
embassy would have been here
today, but unfortunately
they are not here.
But I take it a point
to actually thank them
because it's my forefathers
who left their heritage
and the lands where they had
churned [phonetic] it for years
and centuries and they've
left it in their custody.
I think the Pakistan government
from the unfortunate
circumstances that developed
in 1947 where the two
nations got divided based
on religious tug-of-war,
a civil war that happened,
and communities got
uprooted from both sides.
Ten million people moved in
1947; one million people died.
But yet in seven decades,
I think the government has
started embracing these various
footprints that are there.
The heritage is too large
to be embraced in totality.
Much of it is lost.
But even an effort that embraces
a small magnitude of it,
I think it's a step in
the right direction.
It's a change which can
take a different form
through publications like these
as we create awareness
around the world.
Hopefully, a bigger
change can happen.
But I want to thank
the Pakistan government
for whatever they have embraced.
It's small, but it's
a good start.
I want to thank them also
for having embraced me
and my pursuit for the
creation of the second book,
because the areas that I've
gone in the second publication,
the quest continues
[inaudible] in Pakistan.
I see very, very remote areas,
and some of the [inaudible]
and the areas in the Pakistan
army controlled areas would not
have been actually ever possible
to experience had they not
embraced me and open the gates.
So for that, I want
to thank them also.
Now, before I start, I just want
to actually put down a few --
I want to show you
a small video here.
Sorry; a small video
here of me on the field,
and then I'll get down to the --
[ Music ]
[ Music and Foreign Language ]
So why I'm showing this video is
researching across the country
where there is really
no chartered path,
and you don't know where
these monuments are lying.
For seven decades,
they've been abandoned.
We have history telling us
some of the forts and some
of the bigger structures,
but really to go
inside the interiors --
for instance, this is an
unidentified monument.
I have documented it in my book
because the beautiful
frescoes inside it --
and its state where
it is standing today,
about to fall apart, can
raise a lot of emotion,
and the frescoes convey
a lot of valuable message
as to how our forefathers
were living.
I thought it is important
to document.
But these are the unknown,
unrecognized monuments
wiped out from the history.
I don't even know who
made it, why it was made.
Is there a history
associated with it?
I have no idea.
And that man who was walking
with me right in the beginning,
he basically is that unknown --
I mean, the unknown Pakistani
who became a very good friend of
mine like that that had been 40,
50 people who have embraced
me, and walked in the fields,
in the forests, in the
high hills, and the plains
of Pakistan to make
my work happen.
So that's what I want to
actually convey out of that.
Works like this can be seen
from any community's lens.
Because when a turmoil happens,
turmoil does not impact
one community alone,
and therefore we need to
start by the recognition
that not just the Sikhs,
but all communities suffered
in the violence that -- up
to the civil war that erupted
across the subcontinent in 1947.
If I was to turn this lens
and choose to do this work
out of Muslim legacy,
the story is the same.
If I was to do it from a
Hindu or [inaudible] legacy,
the story is the same.
And therefore, I say in this
slide is Hindu, Muslims, Sikhs,
Christians, Parsis,
Jains, Buddhists,
and I would say even
the Atheists suffered.
Because I don't know what is
the belief system of a man
who projects himself to be
a believer of certain faith.
You don't know inside his heart
whether he really believes
in the existence of God or no.
And yet, the nation was
divided on belief systems of God
in the form of religion, and
which resulted in the hypothesis
that -- it's a big hypothesis
that under the two-nation
theory,
two communities cannot
live together.
The Hindus and the Muslims
cannot live together
as British were leading
the subcontinent.
The assumption was the
two communities cannot
exist together.
From a Sikh perspective,
I have started believing
that the Sikh community was a
mere cucumber in the sandwich.
The third community which
was not even thought of,
and which in this two-nation
theory which emerged,
it was not even put into the
mix until the last moment,
in the last few one or two
years it came into the mix.
And it's -- history had churned,
primarily in the lands
that became Pakistan.
And this painful saga of all
communities, which were divided
in 1947 as British left
the Indian subcontinent,
is described well in
the two-line poetry
of Shah Daman [phonetic], who
says, "[Foreign language]."
Basically, what is means
is that, "The red eyes,
the bloodshot red eyes said
all that both you and we wept."
So we need to start from this
baseline of understanding
as I get into specific subject
of the Sikh legacy in Pakistan.
Now, what I want to
put as a context,
here as Dr. Rajwant just said,
that the Sikh community's
attention has primarily been
focused on just religious
aspects across Pakistan;
not just the Sikh community,
the entire world believes
that the Sikh community's
entire existence
across Pakistan seven decades
after Partition is basically
the few good [inaudible],
the Sikh temples of
worship like [inaudible],
the founder of Sikh was born,
or where some stories attached
with his life, like [inaudible],
or the fifth guru's place plays
like your -- the data side,
and a few more Gurdwaras.
The entire community's
thinking is kind of restricted
on this domain, not
just the Sikh.
The Muslims inside
Pakistan also believe
that this is their heritage,
which we are maintaining
very properly.
Now, I must tell you my
experience when I did this book,
my feeling in giving
the title was, "Yes,
I could have just called it
'The Sikh Legacy in Pakistan',
but sometimes you need
to shake the system,
with a positive intent.
My intent is not here to kind of
finger point and me versus you;
that's not the intent.
The intent is to document,
let's accept what's happened,
let's move forward positively.
But yet sometimes you
have to give a statement,
and therefore I chose
the name of this book --
the title is "The Sikh legacy in
Pakistan", but I chose the name
of the book as "Lost Heritage".
And when I use the
word "lost heritage",
I have taken a long time
to kind of build equity
with the government in Pakistan
that I don't mean wrong.
But yet, the first reaction what
I'm telling you is that even
in Pakistan they
believe that the heritage
of Sikhs is basically
[inaudible], these three, four,
five, six Gurdwaras; and we
have been maintaining it fine.
But writing "Lost
Heritage", the first reaction
that I remember I got from the
Pakistan government itself was,
"Why are you calling
it 'Lost Heritage'?
We have maintained it."
And that's where you
then realize that, boy,
how big a problem it is.
Because when communities get
locked out from the lands
where their generations
have churned the history,
the history just
evaporates; not from the minds
of the community itself
who churned that history
in their land, but also the
ones who own the responsibility
to hold that history
in that land.
It just evaporates
over a period of time.
My forefathers were
not so incompetent
that they only made
four or five Gurdwaras
that the world knows
Pakistan today as.
My forefathers were not
so incompetent that we
as the community, as the
descendant of that generation,
should be only driven to go to
these three or four Gurdwaras.
There is so much more than the
offer; we have simply forgotten.
And therefore, I want to bring
your attention to this slide
where on the black outline you
see the Indians appointment,
which was the British
India, as we know,
in 1947 when they were leaving.
Having come to Calcutta,
they actually started moving.
Sorry, allow me a minute;
I just want to take
my pointer out here.
[ Background Sounds ]
So having come into
Calcutta in the 1700s,
as the British started expanding
with the help of Bengal army,
the Pulbia [phonetic] soldiers,
the [inaudible] regiments,
they started expanding.
They came to the Sutlej
River, and they came to a halt
out here; because the
last standing kingdom,
the independent kingdom at that
time, was this yellow kingdom
which was being ruled by
the Getsing [phonetic],
and its capital was
Lahore [phonetic].
Now, the historical texts, and
especially the British texts,
have written this as
the "Sikh Kingdom".
The Sikhs record themselves
like the [inaudible],
the five portion volumes,
five-volume portion with lots
of day-to-day account
to what was happening
in the Getsing Kingdom
in Lahore.
It was a very detailed account,
which has recently
been translated
into English by the [inaudible].
If you read that --
actually, there's no mention
of Sikh Kingdom or the Sikh raj.
There's nothing like that.
It's simply referred
to it as [inaudible].
The Khalsa is basically
a Puritan concept.
It's a concept which sees
the world in a Puritan form,
which actually allows to
embrace all communities.
It's a very secular
concept, purity, right;
and that's what this
kingdom was termed as.
British call it as
a Sikh Kingdom
because they saw [inaudible],
the man who was ruling
out of Lahore to be a
man who was a believer
of the Sikh faith, and
therefore they call it.
I question that because yes, it
was truly a [inaudible] in terms
of its purity and mindset,
because there were
implementing that.
They had an army, which
comprised of six Hindus,
Muslims, Punjabis for the
first time in 3,000 years
after Pouris [phonetic] attacked
-- Alexander attacked Punjab,
it's the first time
after 3,000 years
that the Punjabis
themselves rules,
and a man of the soil
formed the kingdom.
And yes, prior to that,
the history goes the
[inaudible] formed the kingdom
out of Lahore -- had
taken over Lahore.
But truly a big empire like
that for the first time
in the history of
Punjab, a man of the soil,
Ranjetsing [phonetic] formed it.
And he pulled together people
of all faith, Muslims, Hindus,
Sikhs, rallied around him.
In spite the differences of
faith, they came together
for one cause, and
that was what we call
as "Punjabieth" [phonetic].
And today that Punjabieth seems
to be fragmented,
thanks to 1947.
His foreign minister signed
a treaty with the British
that decided that this was
the line on the east side
of the empire of
the "Sikh Kingdom",
which the British called, which
the British will not cross.
He signed the treaty
with Afghanistan,
which today is known as the
"Duden [phonetic] Line".
You know what, if history
has to be rewritten,
the man who really
signed this treaty
and who should be
given the credit,
it was Fakid Azizudine
[phonetic],
[inaudible] foreign minister,
or Ranjit Singh himself,
because this line was
drawn by them running right
through the Pashtun territory.
But the British actually
having recognized --
felt the need of
recognizing the man
who led the expedition the first
[inaudible] war, which happened
in Kabul going through
[inaudible],
was led by the man
called Duden [phonetic].
So they called this as the
"Duden Line", in recognition.
But really this line was
created by Fakid Azizudine,
the foreign minister
of Ranjit Singh.
All I want to say is that
this [inaudible] stretched
from Ladakh, Kashmir,
Baltistan, Kiberidia [phonetic].
The two nations today
are fighting
over Kashmir, India
and Pakistan.
Millions of people are --
thousands of lives
have been lost
since 1947 in this tug-of-war.
But people have -- are not
even aware today the man
who brought the Ladakh,
Baltistan,
and Kashmir onto
the map of India
and Pakistan is Ranjit Singh;
because if not for him,
Kashmir today would be
a part of Afghanistan,
because the Iranians
were ruling it
for 110 years before he
brought it into the [inaudible],
and then the British
took over the Punjab,
and therefore it became
a part of British India.
All I want to say is that it
would take this mighty empire,
which was the last-standing
empire
of what became British India,
and you lay it over the Pakistan
and India, what you
find is the line of --
the [inaudible] line
runs to here,
and after that it
becomes the line
of control dividing Kashmir.
Eighty percent of that
territory is today in Pakistan;
and that's the one statement I
want to make out of this slide.
Eighty percent of
that territory is
in Pakistan, and
20% is in India.
And therefore, the question
that I'm asking again,
"Were my forefathers
so incompetent
that they only made these
two or three Gurdwaras?"
Right? And therefore, as I
stood at this grave while going
up to Montserrat -- I'm
sorry, this grave is
at Montserrat while going
to Kashmir [inaudible]
at this graveyard -- on this
grave behind these shrubs
and the plants out here you
see behind there's a plaque
out up here on which
is written in Urdu,
"Ghulam Sarwar vald
Makhan Singh."
Ghulam Sarwar, a Muslim, who
lives buried here whose father,
a Sikh, Makhan Singh --
well whose father was
Makhan Singh, a Sikh.
Now, I don't need to know
or I don't have any idea
as to what happened
with Ghulam Sarwar,
why did he convert his faith
and why is he lying buried here?
But the point I'm trying to
make out of this grave is
that legacy is not religion;
because this grave is
also a part of my legacy.
A Sikh's son is lying buried
here, and therefore I see this
as a part of my legacy, and the
story needs to be documented.
And that part when I saw this
grave is what actually motivated
me to embark on this journey
to document in the form
of a publication,
because I did not go
to Pakistan to write a book.
I consider myself as
an accidental author.
I have been in the corporate
world for about 25 years.
I was the regional head for Asia
Pacific for American Express
for the revenue management.
In 2014 for certain
reasons, I left my job
because I had been
there for 25 years;
I was looking for
something else.
But in the six months of
the cooling down period
that I was actually going
through, I just thought
that I need to go up to
Kashmir to my father's place,
because in 1947 when
he was ousted
because of the Kashmir
problem which started
after the Partition
of 1947 of Punjab --
I don't call it as a
Partition of India,
I call it as a Partition of
Punjab and Partition of Bengal,
because that's what it was.
The problem of Kashmir
starts much later.
The problem of Kashmir starts
in October 1947 on the 21st
of October, 1947 when Kashmir
is attacked by the tribal.
And what our forefathers -- my
father, my aunt, my uncle used
to tell us is that they never
could go back to this part
of Kashmir, which
is in Pakistan,
because they then were
shifted and ousted,
and rebuild their
lives in [inaudible].
But he used to tell that on the
morning of 21st October, 1947,
our aunt and uncles got
up to a huge war cry,
which was Hindu [inaudible]
or Sikh [inaudible].
That is a Persian word,
"[Inaudible] the Hindus
and behead the Sikhs."
And on this bridge, about
300 people were rounded up,
306 were rounded up.
And this is the first
attack of Kashmir
which happens [inaudible].
And they were shot
on both the sides.
And then many bodies fell.
My mother-in-law's parents
both died on this bridge
in this unfortunate incident.
There's a chapter in
this first book called
"Meeting Moody [phonetic]."
Moody was [inaudible],
a Sikh girl who now
lives in [inaudible].
She's my distant aunt.
And she lost both her
parents; she was just four
and a half years old,
on this same bridge.
And she has the impression so
strong in her mind that even
at the age of 75 years,
she can recount everything
that happened that day.
Now, a four-and-a-half
year old child recounting,
that's amazing; because I can't
recount what I actually --
what I may have experienced
at the age of ten or 12.
But here's a child -- here's
an old woman who at the age
of four-and-a- half years what
she experiences, recounting it.
And I wanted to go to
this bridge basically
to pick up the soil.
I wanted to pass it down
to our next generation,
our two daughters, just
to remind them that,
"Wherever you go in this global
village that we are living
in today, don't forget
your roots."
And therefore, I decided
in that six-month period
that I was cooling down after
my American Express career
that I must go to Pakistan.
All my vision was that I
wanted to go into Pakistan.
I didn't go to write a book.
I just decided to head
towards [inaudible].
I decided like every
other Sikh that I must go
and visit [inaudible].
But I also knew from
the history books
that a huge glorious chapter
of my tradition actually
happened in these lands.
So I wanted to go
and experience,
"Are there some remnants there?"
I had no idea whether
I will find anything.
And as I therefore embarked on
this journey, on the 15th day
of my journey, I got a 30-day
visa to enter the first time.
On the 15th day, I did reach
[inaudible], and as I picked
up the soil, something within
me said, "Don't do this."
Because passing to the
next generation the soil,
you might be passing down
a memory which I don't want
to pass down of hatred
between communities.
And therefore, I left it.
And I think that I
did the right thing
because what I've done
is more than the soil is
to capture the experiences
in these two books;
that's more valuable
than the soil.
But when I saw the
turning of the Jhelum River
at the [inaudible] -- this is a
town where my father was born,
that u-turn symbolized that
yes the communities did make a
u-turn in 1947.
Hindus, Muslims, Sikhs chose
to look away from each other.
And therefore, when I came
back -- I had been to 36 cities
and villages in 30 days, and
I thought it was important
to write this journey
in the form
of a picture travel
log expressing all
that I had experienced and
telling a little bit of history,
so that posterity can
remember that seven decades
after Partition, someone went
and at that point of time he saw
where the heritage was standing.
Seventy percent of a heritage
is finished is my estimate.
It's my gut estimate.
There's nothing to -- there's
no detail to validate that;
that's my gut estimate
that 70% is finished.
But yet, I felt that it was
important to document it
that we should have
some remnants
to remind our future generations
that this is what it was
seven decades after Partition.
But you know what,
sometimes journeys that seem
to have ended actually are
boiling to take another a shape,
and that's exactly what
was happening to me,
because when I published
this book, I was called
at many forums around the
world to talk about it.
And as I kept on talking,
I realized that having published
a book, I had gone on a journey
around the world speaking
at about some 75 seminars
around the world in
about eight months.
At that point, I felt the
book needs to be left,
I need to go back to
my corporate world,
and I need to start looking
at my daily chores
of earning a living.
But you know what, as I took
up a job deep inside me,
something was disturbing me.
And what was disturbing me
was that I am in my journey
of the first book
had stood at Jamrud,
right at the [inaudible] Pass
where [inaudible] had
made the fort of Jamrud,
and thereafter no envision has
happened from the Khyber Pass
for a good 200-odd years.
Now, is it because of
Jamrud, or is this a matter
of destiny, I don't know.
But yet when the fort was made
after that, the thousand years
of envisions from the
central Asian lands
into the Indian subcontinent
did stop.
I could not go inside there,
because [inaudible] died there,
and yet I wanted to
experience that place
where his body was kept.
And what was there inside that
fort I could not experience it.
Attock -- as I stood at the
Attock River, I was reminded
of that journey that
Alexander Burnes did,
because as the Treaty
of Amritsar was signed
between the British and
the Ranjit Singh in 1809,
saying both sides will
respect each other,
the British already
started sending spies
into Pakistan -- into Punjab.
And the mission was basically
to find out what is the power
of this kingdom,
can we do something,
can we tomorrow take it over?
And as those missions went,
many of the spy missions
submitted the reports --
of course, all of them
submitted reports to Calcutta,
to East India Company, but
some wrote their personal
travel logs.
And I had read these
One of them was William
Moorcroft in 1809 --
1819 he went into Lahore.
And then he went
right up to Kashmir
to Ladock [phonetic]
from Lahore.
But the most interesting one was
where I'm talking about Attock,
because Alexander Burnes had
never stepped into India.
Later on in the first
Afghan war,
he was hacked to death in Kabul.
But he had never come to India.
And he was given this
mission that, "We want to find
out can ships be
taken inside Punjab.
How can you take
ships inside Punjab,
and Punjab does not
even touch the sea?"
So he was put onto
a ship and said,
"Here are five hyper
degree [phonetic] horses.
Take them through
the Arabian Sea,
take it into the industrial
world, and sail it upwards
and see how deep can
you dig the horse --
the ship inside in
the industrial world,
and see here it goes and docks?"
And he sailed with high
hyper-degree horses
to gift it [inaudible]
in Lahore.
That was just a --
gifting was just an excuse
to leave the secret mission.
And he docked the ship at the
Attock Fort, on the industry
where -- and I was
standing there,
and that site looked familiar
because when as a young kid,
I read "The Journey
of Alexander Burnes",
that picture still
imprinted in the mind.
And when I was standing in
the first journey wanting
to go inside the Attock
Fort, I could not go inside,
because both Jamrud
and Attock are
under the control of
the Pakistan army.
Now, layers of generations
and dynasties have actually
played a role in Attock,
like for instance the
[inaudible] under the Sikh rule
in Lahore, then the British --
now the Pakistanis are
actually playing a role.
But I wanted to go inside
because I could see
that picture.
Alexander Burnes came and
docked his ship here to prove
that ships and the navy
could be brought into Punjab.
And if the British
wanted to attack Punjab
from both sides they could
compress it by bringing
in the navy, and from
this side bringing
in the army from [inaudible].
Nothing happened,
actually, on that front.
But Alexander Burnes
wrote his travel log,
how he took the horses
to Lahore and gifted it
to the Ranjit Singh,
beautiful travel logs.
And I in my mind
after the first book
in the nights I would see the
dreams of Attock and Jamrud
as a mission had
been incomplete.
As I looked at this picture
of DGF Newhall [phonetic],
which after the second annual
sea coordinate [phonetic]
in 1949-1851, DGF
Newhall travels
to the Tanamal [phonetic]
Range, along the River Indus,
and [inaudible] and
looks down and marks
where all the Sikh forts were.
And this publication
was published later
on about 20 years later.
And I'm wondering in 1947,
the Sikh community was pretty
much resident in these lands
until 1947, after
which they were ousted.
And why is it that I can't
find any book since the journey
of 1851 of DGF Newhall
until the time of 1947
when cameras has
existed, why hasn't anyone
from my community gone and
simply taken a panoramic image
of that same land and mark where
the forts had once existed?
These were marked
forts, small forts.
So the community today
only associates [inaudible]
with Jamrud, and does not know
anything more about [inaudible]
or his role that he played in
27 forts along the River Indus.
There's documented evidence
of that in the history.
So we don't know.
And I'm thinking this is
valuable to be documented again,
but I am struggling through as
to how does one go
back to Pakistan?
I had experienced it, and I was
wondering how does one go back,
and how does one document this?
But then when you start
believing in something,
strangely enough, the
energies do come together.
And I'm blessed because the
Pakistan government themselves
invited me for a seminar --
for a conference in Islamabad.
And what I had done with my
first book was wherever I went
around the world, I'm
accepting the fact
that Partition has have
happened, I cannot change it,
Pakistan cannot change
it, we cannot change it.
What can we learn from this,
what can we talk in terms
of human values, and what
can we actually bring
about as a positive
change is what I was trying
to spread as a message.
And I think the Pakistan
establishment did appreciate
that the person was not trying
to make it a political pitch
out of it, because
there's enough of politics
and much [inaudible] that's been
happening for years and years.
What do we go going forward?
And I was invited to Islamabad
to take part in a conference
where -- when my first
publication was --
I was not being invited
to talk there,
but I think they recognized
that [inaudible]
someone's done some work
on Pakistan's heritage,
and so they invited me.
In my mind, I thought that
this is the right opportunity
to ask the Pakistan government
that if you think I've
done something all right,
then please open
the gates of Jamrud
and Attock and show it to me.
That is all that I had
asked for, and if possible,
please take me to the
[inaudible] area to see
that forts where they had
existed are there still some
remains lying there?
That's all I envisioned
for and asked.
And as I landed in
Pakistan, a beautiful energy
by the government, and as well
as the people started
engulfing me once again.
And I say this, the work is
thanks to the people of Pakistan
who have actually
enabled this for me,
because as they embraced me,
the energy started engulfing me
to a point I asked
myself, "Do I go back,
or do I continue with this?"
And I think I made
the right choice,
because I could have
easily gone back.
There was a job waiting for me;
I would have actually just
been doing a nine to five,
but I decided to just let
the energy take me forward.
And as it took me
forward, I stayed there
for another 50 days, of
which 40 days I spent
in the search traveling across
Pakistan from Baltistan,
to Kibor, to Punjab, to
Sindh and Balochistan,
and having realized after about
40 days of journey and 50 days
in Pakistan that I'd been to 90
cities and villages this time.
And when I came back, it
was two humungous data
that I had actually
gotten, all for heritage --
a composite heritage of all
of our communities together.
I thought that this
needs to be, again,
documented because
it has not been done.
The future generation needs
to know what had
churned on these lands.
And therefore, I didn't go
back into the corporate world
and started documenting it.
I will share a few stories
before I move on to what the --
a sense of the presentation is
as to what has Amardeep learned
out of his journeys
across Pakistan.
The -- I want to talk about
the remains of a Sikh Gurdwara,
a Gurdwara, a place of
Sikh worship along --
near the river in this --
at a village called
"Codfatikan" [phonetic].
Codfatikan -- this
is the Gurdwara --
these are the remains.
The walls have actually
all broken down.
The gate is just
still standing there.
I go inside there, and I'm
appreciating the beautiful
frescoes inside this
[inaudible] here.
And what I see is that our
forefathers had a very secular
pluralistic mindset; because on
these frescoes, it was Punjabi
that they would have left him.
It was not faiths that
they would have left him.
It was a composite culture, of
stories of the lands of Punjab,
whether it be [inaudible],
whether it be
Than Singh himself,
or if there --
at places, even [inaudible],
you know?
I think what they are trying
to represent is what
Punjab was representing
as a cultural aspect.
Faith and culture are
two sides of a coin,
because we cannot
segregate the two things.
And yes, you're freed
and unorganized, thinking
and religion takes a form
over a period of time.
But yet, cultural aspects cannot
be ignored because faiths emerge
from the foundation of cultures
that churn in a particular land,
and the stories that
churn there.
And I'm looking at these
frescoes in a pretty sad state,
because for seven decades
the community is not there,
they have not been maintained,
they're nearly finishing off.
And my first thought
that comes to my mind is
that the Sikh community
is in a very sad state.
And I coined a statement
altogether,
which I say it all the time
when I go around the world,
"The Sikh community lost it
there, which is in Pakistan
in the creation of 1947, and
moving out of the country,
but the Sikh government
destroyed it here,
which is in East Punjab.
Because frescoes and
monuments like this,
there are none existing
in East Punjab now.
If our heritage, although in a
sad state -- because we have --
we are not existing
in these lands,
and therefore no one can
take care of it, if they're
yet existing, they are
existing in the last forms
in the lands of Pakistan.
In East Punjab, we have
destroyed it all ourselves
because we have a fancy for
modernizing our structures
with marble and gold,
replacing frescoes.
Replacing artworks with a
preference of white marble
and materialistic gold,
we are leaning nothing
for our next generation to delve
into to the beautiful stories
that these frescoes can read.
There's nothing left.
And someone in Delhi had asked
me when I was presenting as to,
"When will you do this work for
the Sikh legacy in East Punjab?"
And my answer was, "I will
never probably do it."
Because my soul finds itself
flying in the stratosphere
when I go to Pakistan,
because these monuments take me
to a different realm altogether.
Only I know what I
experienced in these lands.
In East Punjab, I
cannot feel that.
I feel dead monuments.
I feel the whiteness and
the materialistic imprint
of gold is leaving nothing
for the next generation
to really understand
from where we emerged,
and what value system our
forefathers were trying
to tell us to the art forms.
But as I was standing here,
invariably in my stories
that you'll find in the book,
one or the other old man,
as we call as "Babas" [phonetic]
will definitely appear.
And a Baba appeared out here.
And I've called this Gurdwara
as "Sultan Tansing" [phonetic],
but the Gurdwara actually
is called as "Baba Tansing".
In the Punjabi terminology,
and especially
in the Sikh terminology,
the people whom we revere,
the saints, and the
elevated people as "Baba",
the one who is the
man with the wisdom.
But in the Islamic
tradition, a man with a power,
be it spiritual power,
or a materialistic power,
or a power of military
power is called a "sultan".
So out here, the Baba
Tansing Gurdwara,
the villagers now call
it a "Sultan Tansing".
And I was standing out
here, and a villager,
this old man came in, and
he started talking to me.
He says "Salam" to me.
And I said "Salam" to him also.
And he told a few things.
One thing he said was,
"Every Friday, we still come
to this Gurdwara
we light a lamp."
"Duma" [phonetic] is a
Friday pass [phonetic].
And after that what he said is,
"All the villagers come here
and as a mark of respect
for seven decades we've been
lighting a lamp out here."
Now, whatever the
politics may have done,
whatever the divisions
may have been, the mans
or the villages seeing voice
of humanity is still wanting
to associate with the fact that
this was the largest monument
of that village, and a
tradition must be kept alive,
and therefore they
put a lamp out there.
And as I'm looking at the
various writings on the wall,
at one place -- at most of
the places where things are,
our forefathers used to
only use two languages.
The more westwards you
go, you will only find
in the Sikh Gurdwaras,
only Urdu and [inaudible].
There's to be no Hindi
[inaudible] script.
And as I'm looking at the Urdu
and the Guruki [phonetic],
at the Urdu places, there
has been some black paint
which has been put through.
And I could read through that,
that wherever "Baba
Tansing" has been written,
it's been blackened.
But adjacent to that,
wherever [inaudible]
"Baba Tansing" is written,
it's not been blackened.
So I asked the Baba himself,
the man of wisdom who was there,
"Why have they blackened
the places where in Urdu,
'Baba Tansing' is written?
And his reply to
me was beautiful.
What he says is, "You
know, the villagers say
that he was indeed Baba
Tansing for the Sikhs,
but now he's our Sultan Tansing.
It's yet the emotion for that
man, emotion for that place,
which is being held
on, is the value
that I want actually people to
take away from these things,
that humans do care;
humans do care.
But ill-fated well, I --
unfortunately the narratives --
you know, history is his
story, whose story you want
to listen to; it's
always biased.
And it always takes
rising above to understand
that sometimes history
has to be understood.
Most of the time, history
needs to be laid out of biases
to be really understood.
Unfortunately, when I presented
the Sikh legacy in Pakistan
in terms of our two
books in Delhi,
one of the [inaudible]
actually got them,
and she made a very valid point
because I was alluding to it.
I said, "The Sikhs were
basically a cucumber
in the sandwich
in the [inaudible]
concept of Hindu and Sikhs.
Hindus and Muslims
cannot stay together.
And what basically what happened
was that our entire history,
unfortunately, doesn't find
prominence in the textbook
in Pakistan, but our history
does not even find prominence
in the textbooks in India.
It's just a passing
mention of the Sikh gurus,
and it finishes off; because
I've studied history out there ,
nd I've seen the
history books in Pakistan
of the Punjabi University.
And looking at that it pains
me, because the history
which basically churn on these
lands has been forgotten,
because probably in Pakistan,
this was a non-Islamic era,
and in India, it's a
history that churned
in the lands of Pakistan.
So from both the sides, I see
it's the unfortunate thing is
that the Sikhs have lost
the element of the history,
and therefore we own
the responsibility
of owning the history ourselves;
no one's going to
protect it for us.
We have to protect it ourselves.
And therefore, when I looked
at the Partition violence --
I must remind that Partition
violence [inaudible] divided,
which is unfortunate, because
Punjab could not have been
divided in any form or any way.
There were multiple
formulas being expressed,
but yet what happened was on
the blood of the common Punjabi,
two nations were created.
But Punjab was a composite
culture where Muslims, Hindus,
and Sikhs had stayed
together for centuries,
and lived, coexisted together.
But it was divided.
But what people have
forgotten is
that Punjab was the last
state to experience violence
in the violence of India
that divided the nation.
The nation's violence did
not start from Punjab.
It started from as
far away in the East
in Calcutta in 1946 August.
And it spread into
[inaudible] in Bengal,
it spread into [inaudible],
Muslims got massacred.
And as waves of Muslims
moved towards Sindh,
many passed through Punjab.
Punjab was fine because
Punjab was being ruled
by a secular party of
[inaudible] who had Muslims,
Hindus, and Sikhs collectively
representing the Punjab
government under
the British regime.
And Punjab did not face
any problem until actually
under pressure [inaudible]
resigns on the 3rd
of March 1947, resulting in
a questioning by the Sikh
and the Hindu leadership,
and thereafter,
a wave of genocide emerges in
the villages around Rawalpindi.
And this particular village,
[inaudible], is documented
to be the first village
where the violence occurred.
And this is the remains
of the [inaudible].
And I wanted to go
here to document this
because what happened here
was 75 women on the fifth
of sixth day after being locked
inside the [inaudible] came out
and jumped inside this well.
And I wanted to document this.
And I went inside to Khalsa,
and I was looking for the well.
And this Baba, again,
an old man of wisdom,
strangely appears on the road.
And I stopped the [inaudible]
and I looked down at him
and I got down and I went to
him and I said, "Baba Salam."
And he looks at me and he says,
"Where have you come from?"
And he was surprised.
And he gave me a hug and I
asked him, "Baba, tell me,
where is that well where
75 women, history tells us,
jumped inside on the seventh
of eighth of March 1947?"
He took out his spectacles,
wiped his tear, and he says,
"You know what, I
was 18 years old
and it happened in
front of my eyes."
What is the probability
of walking on the streets
and you stumble upon someone
who has been a live
witness to the entire event?
And as I actually followed
him, he took me to the place.
And I felt that this well
needs to be documented
because the tragedy of Punjab,
which resulted in displacing
of communities and
creating a drift among us
for forever actually
I had to document it.
And I've done that in this
book, because it's important
for the next few generations.
I again thank the
Pakistan government
that they enabled my trip inside
the Jamrud Fort, and this time
in the second book, I was
standing on top of this bastion
and looking on this side
towards the Kibor Pass,
and the two mountains
coming and meeting.
And what a picture it is
I've taken in my second book
of showing the mountains
coming down.
For one thousand years the
[inaudible] had come there
into the subcontinent.
And when this fort was made
in 50 days, thereafter,
the history has not
had any invasion.
Because of this fort, or
because of other reasons --
there could be many
other factors,
but history does also
points that after this fort,
construction at the Kibor there
has been no further envision.
As I walked up to this
site of the bastion,
the room where [inaudible]
body was kept
after he died battling the
Afghan envision into Punjab,
for three days he was
kept in this room.
On the other side yet in
Urdu is written the incident
which led to his death.
And when I was growing up,
I looked at this room falling
apart, I requested the commander
in the fort that, "Please,
don't let this room go away."
We don't know what happens with
the history going forward or --
sorry, not with the
history, with the boundaries,
or with the passport
regimes, or regional regimes,
we don't know what the
future has in store for us.
But if this room falls apart,
the sentiments associated
with the Sikhs for this
one room are so large,
but tomorrow the tourism
potential for Pakistan is
so strong inside this that
this can become the next wave
to begin the Sikhs to show them
their heritage in Pakistan.
So don't let this go.
I was promised by the
commander that they will look
into actually getting this room
restored, but I hope they do.
As I looked at this in
[inaudible], this Gurdwara,
I was reminded -- I
was taken [inaudible]
of the 92-year-old Baba
inside the village in Kashmir,
who tells me a beautiful story.
He -- as I -- not -- I
mean, he told not a story,
but beautiful experiences.
As I sat with him, I
was having a cup of tea,
92-year-old man speaking
very softly
and he started reciting
the first two verses
of the [inaudible]
composition of [inaudible]
and he goes, "[Foreign
language]."
And I looked at him, I said,
"Baba, how do you know this?"
He says, "Sultan Singh
[phonetic] was a great man.
The man who led this Gurdwara
and established mane," he said,
"There should be a
Khalsa school next to it."
And I tell you in Pakistan
I've been to many schools,
the government schools, the
Islamia [phonetic] schools,
and it has made me
reflect that the Sikhs
in leading the lands gave
up billions of dollars
of educational investments.
Because what the Baba had said
is what many people have told me
of the olden age, he
says, "We used to aspire
to go to Khalsa schools."
The Khalsa schools
had a brand name,
and Sikhs have invested a
lot of investments at that,
and therefore if you go into
many of these government schools
and Islamia schools,
and you will find --
and I've shown many of them,
[foreign language] something
in [foreign language]
inside them.
You don't have to look for them,
because in seven decades a lot
of it is finished now.
But it made reflect what
kind of investment we had
to walk away from,
because going into India,
the Sikh community has tried
to reestablish the Khalsa brand
of schools and colleges.
We have done it.
But I ask myself this
question, "Did I choose
to join the Khalsa College?"
When I got admission there in
Delhi, I chose to decline it
because the reputation
is not too great.
Sometimes when your umbilical
cord is severed from ages
of investments that you
made to build a brand,
and you are severed from it,
you may not be able to create
that impression once again.
And that's the thing
I experienced.
But he tells me that,
"We used to inspire to go
to the Khalsa school."
And he says, "I studied there."
And he says, "I used to a
lot of time in the Gurdwara."
And then he said a very
interesting statement,
which made me reflect, Punjab
was destined to be divided
because of our own fault.
There's a lot of
positivity in these lands,
because faiths had
lived together for ages,
and we used to live
together for centuries.
But he made a very
interesting statement,
which made me reflect.
What he said was, "We used to --
" Sultan Singh was a very
great man because the longer --
the tradition of community
kitchen used offer free food
to everyone 365 days
a year 24 hours.
And then he makes a comment,
he says, "We used to pick
up sucalangar [phonetic]."
"Sucalangar" means
"dry rations".
I know the reason why he said
that; I just probed him further.
I said, "If the food
was being made, Baba,
why would you pick
up dried rations?
Just pick up the
food and eat it."
And he smiles at me
and he says in Punjabi,
he says, "[Foreign language]."
He says, "You know the antics
of the religion,
what it makes us do."
Basically, what he was alluding
to was on the Lahore station,
there should be two parts
of water as documented,
one part used to be for Hindu,
and the other for Muslims.
And the water used to be
filled from the same tap.
What it means is that if you
can't drink from the same part,
if you can't eat from
the same utensils,
Punjab had a hairline fracture.
In spite of all the
positiveness,
there was a hairline fracture,
which was used to the advantage
of the British when they
were dealing and was creating
into a communal mindset.
And because of political
motives and the reasons --
other political reasons
it had led to a separation
and severance of
centuries of civilizations
that have learned
to exist together.
But as I was leaving,
he said a very, very --
very, very heart-touching
thing to me.
He says, "Will you
go back to India?"
And I said, "Sometimes, yes,
I stay in Singapore I
sometimes yes will."
And he says, "Can you
do a favor for me?"
And I said, "Tell me."
He says, "Can you go and appeal
to the people, the Hindus
and Sikhs of Alibage [phonetic],
if they are there anywhere
in India, that they
must come back now?"
In his saying that he had
reflected a huge amount
of emotion, because
what he wanted to do was
to bring about a closure.
And I looked at him and I said,
"Baba, how is this possible?
The countries, and the nations,
and the politics have divided us
so deeply that there's
no return on this."
He says, "I understand.
But if you can convey my
message, I am about to die.
But I would like to see the
people with whom I grew,
and I will return -- I
know where the lands were,
and I will return
that land to them."
I just smiled and walked away
because it's not possible now.
But the emotion of
that man said a lot.
I went up to Baltistan -- I want
to make a small point out here,
the remains of the Gurdwara
in Baltistan, in Skardu,
and the fort, which was
taken and made a part
of the Lahore Darbar [phonetic],
the two battalions in 1840,
which went from Lahore were led
into Zorawar Singh
and Mohiud-din-Shah.
And the person whom they fought
out here was Amit
Shah [phonetic].
The point I'm trying to make out
of these names is the following.
These were not wars
based on religion.
People just get it wrong.
I have done an article about
Zorawar Singh 30 years in search
of Zorawar Singh, because
I've traveled strangely
and unknowingly deep into Tibet
and other areas of Ladakh,
and in Pakistan where Zorawar
Singh actually laid a footprint,
right?
He was an employee
of the Darbar.
And when I wrote an article
about him, people turned around
and said, "Was -- " starting
a tug-of-war on the Internet.
And the question is whether
Zorawar Singh was a Hindu,
or a Sikh.
And I'm looking at
this tug-of-war --
basically it's tugs-of-war,
because when I am a Sikh working
for American Express,
the leadership never asked
me what my faith was.
They paid me for my loyalty
to the American Express
Organization.
And the organization here
was the Lahore Darbar.
And in respect to the fact that
Mohiud-din-Shah was a Muslim,
Zorawar Singh was a --
was probably a Hindu or
Sikh, who knows his faith.
And [inaudible] was a Sikh.
They were all giving their
loyalty to the kingdom,
and not based on their faith.
And yet, these two people who
went inside with the battalions,
Mohiud-din-Shah leading
one battalion,
and Zorawar Singh
leading one battalion,
fighting against the Amit Shah
should be a reflection to show
that this was not a time
where the Punjabis were
fighting on religion.
Because a Muslim could stand on
the other side and be fighting
against another Muslim, because
they were loyal to a territory,
and not because of religions.
That's the point I
want to make out there.
And I think this
Baltistan, the documentation
that I've given inside this
book, interesting there.
I find a very -- I went to
the ministry corporation
and I was showing some documents
there that after this expedition
of 1840 all the lands of Skardu
were turned into the title-ship
under Lahore Darbar of
Khalsa Sarkar [phonetic],
the government of Khalsa.
And today, yet, when you take
a lease title inside Skardu,
the original title-ship
of that land is held
by Khalsa Sarkar;
in the documents.
And I've shown the
picture of that.
What I want to share here
is the beloveds of Nanak,
what the people have forgotten.
And what Pakistan
themselves does not know is
that there are one million
people in Sindh, in Balochistan,
and in certain areas of Swat,
Mardan, and other places,
who are believers of Guru Nanak.
Loosely, they're all called
by everyone as "Hindus".
But ask them who they are.
They are opening more and
more Gurdwaras in the format
that the Sikhs of
Punjab worship in.
Similar kind of Gurdwaras, 200
of them I've seen actually --
I've not documented all of them,
but about 200-plus Gurdwaras
in Sindh and Balochistan
had been opened up.
These are the communities
that are forgotten.
If you look at the
[inaudible], the writings
of Gurnarniks verses [phonetic],
and the ladies were
sitting out here.
They look very least
like the Punjabi ladies
or the Sikh ladies.
But yet, their faiths are all
about Gurnarnik and
their attachment.
This community of Nanak
Panthis needs to be studied,
needs to be brought to the
limelight, because in India
after the Partition, this
community has amalgamated
into the broader faiths of
the land, and moved away
from the association of Nanak.
Is it because of we
have not held them,
or have they been
loosely bounded
into a religious boundary
that they have found
the ways to merge?
But yet in Pakistan, one million
such people are still existing.
I have actually --
I say it openly
that maybe the Pakistan
government should ask the
Sindhis and the Balochis
what is their faith?
Maybe an open-ended question
will tell us what do they
feel like.
Because when I'm
talking to them,
they are telling me
something very different.
I asked [inaudible], who is
the head priest of a Gurdwara,
they don't want to
have any temples.
They believe in the grand
side, the same practices
as the Sikh community.
They may not look like us in
terms of our turban and beard,
but they believe in all
the elements of the faith.
They have not graduated to
the tradition of Khalsa,
but yet they believe in all
the elements of the faith.
And I asked Banasree Lalgi
[phonetic] a question
for which he gave me
very interesting answer.
I asked him at the Langa
[phonetic], I said,
"Banasree Lalgi, "Can you
tell me how many Hindus
in Pakistan are believers
of Guru Nanak?"
And he looks at me and he says,
"Amardeep, it's so unfortunate
that you still don't
consider us as Sikhs."
So I say to the Pakistan
government,
"Let's ask them what they are."
Because what Pakistan claims
that there are 14,000
turban-wearing Sikhs is the
definition that the
world sees them as.
I see there could be a one
million number sitting there.
And the game could
change in Pakistan
about what the Sikh faith is
going through around the world.
And I think they
should start from there.
Therefore, I believe the next
phase of studies need to be done
about these forgotten
Nanak Panthis communities
in Afghanistan, in Pakistan, and
how they've evolved in India,
because there's a huge story out
here to be told to the world.
I went to Quetta in Balochistan.
I want to show you this
group of Nanak Panthis.
In the Gurdwara they have two
[inaudible] lying out here.
And all of them or none
of them they want their --
all have their heads covered
in the Sikh tradition.
But there's only one
turban-wearing Sikh out there.
They're all people without
Singh and [inaudible]
as their last names,
and the [inaudible]
that they have there are
two of them, one of them is
in Gurmukhi, and one is in Urdu.
The Urdu Ghansi [phonetic]
have stopped getting printed
in India.
They don't exist anymore.
In Pakistan, too, they are
not being printed anymore,
because the last Ghansi in
Urdu that was printed was
in Hyderabad in somewhere
in mid 1950s.
The demand suddenly died.
Some of these far-off places the
communities are still holding
onto some of the Urdu
script Ghansis, right?
And when I went to the school
in Quetta, the largest school
out there called the
"Special School" --
I thought it was a
special needs school,
but I was still wondering
whether
in Pakistan's special
needs is such a big subject
that you will have
such a big premises
for just special needs kids.
I went there; and it was a
Saturday, so I had requested
to go inside, and the watchman
said that, "Today is Saturday
and you can't go inside
because the school is closed."
I had questioned him and I
said, "Can you please call
up the headmaster
and request him that,
"A Sikh has come
from Singapore?"
And he did that and the
headmaster replied and he says,
"Ask him to wait
there; I'm coming down."
And in 20 minutes he was there.
He took me to his office.
Inside his office, these
black and white pictures
on the wall -- this is one of
the pictures taken from there.
This shows the hockey team.
Sixty percent of the team
of pre-1947 were
turban-wearing Sikhs.
In the Indian subcontinents,
Sikhs were known
as the masters of hockey.
And today, we've moved so
far away from that sport;
very few Sikhs who are
playing hockey itself.
And I am looking at this.
The Hindu Sikhs Muslims sitting
in this team, the
names are below.
And I asked Tokasab [phonetic],
"Tokasab, can you tell me --
" and he also has got the
picture of the founder
of the school on the wall.
And I asked him, "Can you tell
me, why is the school called
"Special School," you know.
And his answer is the most
beautiful answer I heard.
He says, "You know, the Sikhs
made this huge Khalsa school,
and in 1947 simply left
it here and walked away.
Isn't it such a beautiful
special act
that they gave it
to us as a gift?"
I didn't have anything to say.
I said, "Sir, you
are the man of hearts
out here who's torn
my heart," you know.
And he had said a lot in that.
Now, you know, I could go on
and on with these stories,
but I'm sure you'll read the
book, you'll find these stories.
In the interest of time,
I want to tell you what
has Amardeep learned
out of these journeys,
out of these frescoes,
out of these artworks, which
don't exist in India anymore,
and do not motivate me to
do these works in India.
But Pakistan has these
footprints, the communities,
the artworks, the
frescoes, and I feel an honor
that the Pakistan government
has permitted me to go inside
and do these things,
because the story needs
to be told to the world.
What was the story of the past,
and what has Amardeep
taken away?
This can take hours and
hours, and I can go on.
You know, I've -- I talk
for two hours in some places
about the Sikh military legacy
that I mentioned in Pakistan.
I've talked about the
Nanak Panthis themselves,
the believers of
Nanak in Pakistan.
But today, I'm just going
to give you a stratospheric
view quickly of what is it
that I've seen from a legacy
perspective in Pakistan.
And basically, the question
that I get asked many times is,
"Tell us how many Sikhs
are living in Pakistan."
Now, I say the long
and the short answer
of that is the following.
The short answer is when the
violence of 1947 happened,
the Muslims got wiped
out from East Punjab.
As I said from the starting,
"[Foreign language]."
"All communities
have cried in this."
And therefore, if I was to
do this work in East Punjab,
I would say the Muslim story
is the same as our story;
because they got
wiped out there, too.
But when I look, my subject
is [inaudible] in Pakistan,
so therefore I'm
going to look at that.
So therefore, I've marked
this red section here Punjab
and Kashmir, the entire Sikh
and Muslim population
pretty much wiped out.
As much would happen on
this side of East Punjab.
But this pocket of close to
Pashabar [phonetic] and close
to Afghanistan border, the
Sikh community so wiped.
Sikh community as we define
as [inaudible], and turban,
and beard, and so
on and so forth,
all the defined religious
boundaries of the faith,
the people following that -- the
descendants of that today are 14
to 15 thousand in number.
And they are living as
respectable citizens.
A lot of people ask
me, you know,
"Are not minorities facing
challenges in Pakistan?"
You know what I say,
"Which country do minorities
don't face challenges,
or which countries does not
have challenges; tell me."
It exists even in the most
developed nations like US
and the other places
that exist, right,
we've got problems everywhere.
But to say that a community
is being persecuted,
I think you are just
jumping to conclusion.
Don't jump to what the
media is trying to tell you.
Live there and understand
people are surviving,
people are living.
1947 was an aberration,
an unfortunate aberration,
which no one can correct;
you and I cannot correct.
But to say that everything
is a [inaudible]
in somewhere is not being fair.
Right? And therefore, when I
look at this group of people,
they've moved everywhere in
Pakistan, and they are living
as respectable citizens.
There was someone who
said the other day,
and he was making a wrong
statement, I think in one
of my forums someone that
said, and I didn't correct them
because it's not right to
at that point say anything.
But someone -- people have
a belief that someone saying
that Nanganaside
[phonetic] is a place
where the Sikh communities
survive.
No; Nanganaside is in Punjab
here; and it's a red portion.
Everyone was wiped out,
just like Muslims got
wiped out, out here.
But today, the descendants
of this population
from here are living
in Nanganaside,
and there's a very large,
vibrant Sikh community staying
in Nanganaside, but they
are not Punjabi Sikhs.
They are Pashtun Sikhs from
this region who speak Pashto
as their default
language at home.
The problem with the Sikh
community of Punjab is
that they always want to equate
Sikhs is equal to Punjabis.
It is wrong, because Sikhs
are also equal to Kashmirs;
Sikhs are also equal to
Afghanis; Sikhs are also equal
to Pashtun people;
Sikhs are also equal
to Sindhis and Balochis.
A cultural affiliation has
nothing to do with the religion
or the belief system of
a person, and therefore,
all the people that can
tell you, except for one
or two families whom
I know, all the other
in Nanganaside today
are the descendants
of this Pashtun Sikh community.
But what I want to talk about is
this blue area, back here close
to Punjab and Kibor,
[inaudible],
and down here along the River
Indus, 50 kilometers east
of Indus, right up to
Afghanistan border into Quetta
and Balochistan is what I
call as the "Nanakpanthis".
"Panth", for those people
who do not understand the
Indian terminologies or --
"panth" is basically
a community, "Nanak",
the belief -- the
founder of Sikh faith.
The community that
belongs to Nanak,
the founder of the Sikh faith
was a very, very large section
of people, and many of
them lived along the Indus.
Most of them actually
lived along the Indus belt.
And this community, the ones
who do not adopt the Sikh
Khalsa traditions are formed
of an organized Sikh
traditions are the ones
who are living along
these pockets.
And in their minds they
think they are Sikhs.
Now, in the last 25 years,
here's what's happening
in Pakistan.
And I say this openly,
that if there is anyplace
that Sikhism is on
rise, it's in Pakistan.
It's a very bold statement
I'm making, but I've seen it.
It may be in small
numbers, but it is on rise,
because this community
out here has opened
over 200 Gurdwaras inside this.
They are not historical
Gurdwaras,
but they have been opened.
This community out here has
no temples, no Hindu temples
that they go to, but they
only go to Gurdwaras,
and they believe in [inaudible].
And therefore, I talk about
[inaudible] discussion.
It's a community that needs
to be evaluated, studied,
understood, because this
community has dispersed
in India and lost its roots.
They are still surviving
out here.
One hundred of the community
in Buner, which is lying here,
in the last 20 years, 100%
of the next generation
of this community they are
not Singhs and [inaudible],
they are Lall, Kumper
[phonetic], [inaudible];
100% of them have embraced the
Sikh form in the last 20 years.
So this is what the
community's footprint is;
but 1947 what happened is
the community got dispersed
into the Gangetic belt.
Now, civilizations
historically survived
and thrived along the riverbeds.
Boundaries never used to exist.
That's why we have the
Niles civilization,
or we have the Amazon
civilization,
we had the Indus civilization,
we had the Gangetic
civilization.
The people of the Indus
civilization, we the people
of the five rivers, the
five rivers which ran
into the Indus were dispersed
into the Gangetic belt.
And as the dispersal happens,
as one of the US-based
studies says,
"When communities get
dispersed out of force,
the first generation
becomes quiet,
the second generation
becomes confused,
the third generation
remains confused,
and some of them
start asking questions
as to what their roots are."
We are going through that phase.
It happened with the Jews also.
It has happened with
every other community.
If you ask a Syrian
seven decades
from now what's happening there,
and as they're getting
displaced,
it is the same answer
you will get.
And therefore, we,
as we landed here,
why do you think ten
million or one-third
of nearly Sikh communities
moving out --
living outside of India?
It's probably this was
a stop gap arrangement,
because we had lost our roots,
and now it doesn't matter,
the world is our roots.
And we're going to
make roots everywhere.
So we are descendants of a
displaced community who have not
yet found our roots firmly,
and yet we are planting.
But as an outcome of
that, the impact has been
on our philosophy, our culture,
our language, and our heritage;
because we've lost
it from our roots,
the land where our roots were.
And I want to briefly talk
a little bit about that.
Guru Nanak is typically shown in
art forms in across East Punjab,
Sindh, Balochistan, West Punjab,
and Kashmir area, and Kabul,
as a man sitting under
the big canopy of a tree,
and his Muslim companion,
[inaudible] playing the rabab,
and his Hindu companion,
[inaudible], standing
next to him.
What he's saying is, I talk
to both Hindus and Turkeys."
He's not saying, "I talk to
both Hindus and Muslims."
This is a very fine
thing out here.
In the interest of time, I will
not going to get into depth
out here, but what I want to
point out is in the [inaudible]
where this is, the
[inaudible] are saying,
"Hindu [foreign language]."
Hindu and Turak [phonetic]
I'm talking to,
these are two culture.
Today, Hinduism is
considered to be a religion,
but the word "Hindu"
as a religion was not even
existing in the way it does.
It only started happening
in 1980 onwards
when the Turuks came to
the industrial world,
and they looked at a
civilization that lived
on that side as the
civilization of the Sindhu,
and they could not say so and
"Si", and they said "Hindu";
that was a civilization.
And therefore, [inaudible] says
this properly, "Hindu Turak".
He's talking about
two civilizations,
he's not talking
about two faiths.
Because in the civilization
of the east of Indus,
the word "sopta"
[phonetic], and the word --
"the weak", "sopta" in
the Turkic civilization,
in the Central Asia,
in Afghanistan
and other places
becomes "hafta".
"Sir" becomes a "her",
"Sindhu" becomes a "Hindu".
And therefore, the people
on this side was Turkeys --
on this side on the
West were Turkeys,
and this side were
the Sindhu people.
And therefore, he's talking
about Sindhu and Hindu --
Sindhu, the Hindu people and the
Turkey, I'm telling both of them
that humanity is what matters.
And therefore, all his
pictures were always
about the three coming together.
And in Pakistan in most of
the monuments of the Sikh
and Hindu era --
Sikhs and Hindus --
now there are Sikhs and
Hindus, you'll find --
because it was a
Punjabi population;
you'll find this is
very commonly put there.
In the Sufi traditions, there
are many Sufis who yet believe
in Guru Nanak, though they
may be Muslims and Sufis.
They yet respect Guru Nanak
in the Pakistan tradition.
And therefore, when I talk
about philosophies divided,
I make this point,
of the various --
when I said that a legacy
is reduced to religion,
this is how philosophies
get divided, because today
when the Sikhs go to Pakistan
on a religious circuit,
the Pakistanis themselves do
not see beyond the Nanak side
and Punjab side, as the
treasurer and the [inaudible]
of heritage that
lies in Pakistan.
The Sikhs themselves do not
see beyond the Nanak side,
Punjab side.
It's a problem, because
when we go to Pakistan --
I've asked this question to my
community, "Tell me when you go
to Lahore how many of you have
gone as south to [inaudible]
to see Baba Farid's
[phonetic] place?"
And there's virtually no one
until late has raised his hand.
In the Sixth Scripture,
Baba Farid, the Sufi sain,
his writings were given a
place by Guru Nanak himself,
because he went to [inaudible]
to bring his writings.
And when we bound the front of
the Scripture, I actually give
as much of respect to Baba Farid
as I give to Danak [phonetic].
And if I can go to Guru
Nanak's place in Nanganaside,
I should also go to
Baba Farid's place.
But I don't.
I did, but we as a
community, we don't.
And we prefer to go to all the
other places like the market,
shopping, eating, blah,
blah, blah, but we don't want
to go to these places.
Sain Mian Mir's place, Guru
Arjan Dev, the fifth guru,
actually when he was
laying the foundation stone
of Golden Temple,
what did he do as part
of a very pluralistic message
he invited the sain from Lahore,
"Sain Mian, you need
to come to [inaudible]
and lay the first foundation
stone of the Golden Temple
of [inaudible]," which is
the Mecca Medina of Sikhs.
And yet, I ask this question,
"How many of the Sikhs who go
to Lahore even go to
Sain Mian's place?"
You may not go there to worship,
we're not asking with worship,
but as much as I can worship
at my home, I don't need to go
to [inaudible] to worship,
because there is no place
for pilgrimage in
the Sikh philosophy.
But yet, people do go because
of their hearts being attached
to those places.
Something reminds them, "By my
going to Baba Farid's place,
or by my going to Sain Miam's
place, I'm not worshiping there,
something attaches and
reminds me of the value systems
of what my forefathers
used to strive for."
And therefore, how many
of Muslims are going
to Guru Nanak's place,
a tradition of Punjabis,
where we used to coexist amongst
each other, today are divided.
And it has been many times at
[inaudible] Gurdwara in Lahore,
where Guru [inaudible]
was martyred,
when the security people asked
my friend, a Muslim friend,
to show his identity card, and
stopped him from going inside
because he's a believer of
Muslim faith, it pains me.
And I've asked him
so many times,
"Why would you stop
him to go inside?"
He says, "It's for
your security, sir."
And I say, "You know what, if
you have to give my security,
put three layers of security
out here, check them,
but don't stop them
from going inside
because he create barriers.
How do we come together
as people?"
So that's what has happened
as our philosophies
have gotten divided.
I want to talk about
some frescoes.
Punjabis respected Guru Nanak.
And therefore, I -- in
comparative understanding
of religions, one has to
now go into the other faiths
to understand, "How did
they view my faith?"
But when I ran into a lot
of these frescoes
inside the temples,
which have also been
equally lying abandoned,
most of the temples
you'll find these frescoes
or the Sikh gurus, the
Guru Nanak is sitting
and the nine Sikh gurus along
with him, and [inaudible].
Now, whatever did the other
items and other things inside,
the point I'm trying
to simply reflect
out here is the believers
of that faith equally
respected the Sikh tradition.
And this has gotten fragmented,
this has gotten finished off
in East India; because we
have gotten compartmentalized
into who we are.
We don't need to
become the other faith.
I know organized
religions always have their
own boundaries.
But we don't need to
forget that the others
and your forefathers were
respecting these visionary
people, whic, because Punjab
went to not one division,
Punjab has gone through five
divisions, once in the creation
of 1947 of India and Pakistan.
Thereafter India itself got
divided into Chandigarh,
into Himachal, into
Haryana, and into Punjab.
What we are left with Punjab
is not what our forefathers had
played in a turf, which
ran from Chandigarh
and beyond right up to Lakibar.
That's the land where our
forefathers return together
across faiths.
And this is what these
frescoes tell us,
that people of all
faiths respected the Sikh
religion also.
>> Where is this from?
>> Amardeep Singh:
Oh, this one is
from [inaudible] is a village.
But you know what, how
many of these do you want?
My depository is filled
with such pictures.
>> Was all that at [inaudible]?
>> Amardeep Singh: Pardon
me, [foreign language]?
>> Was all this at [inaudible]?
>> Amardeep Singh:
Of course, of course;
there's always [phonetic].
>> It's symbolic.
>> Amardeep Singh:
It's symbolic, yes.
You know, it takes -- it
requires a different mind
or a different attention to go
into these art forms of that
and even start looking at these
all the way in the bad shape,
to understand even
these small things,
if you're noticing a tree,
I'm sure you put a more
concentrated vision into this,
you will find so many things
coming out, as you will see
in the next one, I'll
tell you what I saw.
Because you need a
minute observation
of these things to understand.
If you just go to give a
peripheral cursory glance,
you will not understand
most the things.
So I went into the mausoleum
of Hazrat Shah Shams
Tabrez of Multan.
Because the [inaudible] Multan,
Multan was a land of Sufis.
The Sufis sent him
a bowl of milk,
symbolizing that this place is
filled with spiritual people;
there's no place
for anyone else.
He kept a few jasmine
petals, saying that the milk
that did not spill;
all can coexist.
And the milk -- the
bowl was sent back.
Then after then he came inside
Multan, and he went inside
to this place of Hazrat Shah
Shams Tabrez, and there is
to be historical [inaudible] say
that there should be
Gurdwara close to this.
Remembering Guru Nanak's visit,
I could not find the remains
of the Gurdwara, but what
I found was as I entered,
this Baba was sitting here.
And he tells me after ages
the Sikh has returned.
And as I walked inside and
went around on these fresco --
on these wall paintings
and so on, so forth,
what you look at it is out here.
And I've given this
in my first book,
what you find is names
written in Gurmukhi of Sikhs.
Now, I came running back
to this Baba, and I said,
"You said after ages,
the Sikh has come back.
Who is writing these
Gurmukhi names?"
Because in Pakistan, no one's
writing Gurmukhi names up here,
right, and these are very old
Scripture writings, right?
So he says, "Oh, these
were written before 1947."
Now, what it means is
because Guru Nanak came here,
there was a crisscrossing.
No one is saying that we
are believing in the grave,
or we are doing this and that;
that [inaudible] theology
and philosophy aspects.
But simply as a mark of respect,
sometimes traditions
remind us of our leaders.
Why do we follow our
leaders' traditions;
it's because it reminds us
of what the message they
were trying to convey.
Right; and that's what
to me this was reflective
of that our forefathers had no
barriers to go into this place
to remember what Nanak
was actually pursuing.
And therefore, architectural
message, I want to talk
about the [inaudible]
Gurdwara, there is place
that can we restore
as a collective fort,
because the Pakistan government
has moved a lot from the time
in 1947 when only
Nanganaside was operational,
to today there are 24 historical
Gurdwaras that are operational.
Now, I'm not talking about the
200 Gurdwaras of Nanak Panthis
that are seen in Baluchistan,
who have community Gurdwaras
of the people who
are living there.
But I'm talking about
the historical Gurdwaras,
they've renovated
about 24 of them.
But are they renovated in the
way history and the heritage --
not the history, the
heritage should be maintained;
I think that's where
the a question mark is,
and I think that's a
problem not just of Pakistan,
that's a problem of the entire
Punjabi community, I would say.
Because I've been to the
mausoleum of [inaudible].
I've been to Varishad's
[phonetic] mausoleum,
and I find that they have also
been modernized to the last bit.
The problem is of the culture,
the people who don't understand
what heritage maintenance is.
You don't build on the
heritage, you build around it.
You preserve that grave.
You build around it.
You don't build on that
grave a more modern grave.
Right; I think that's
the problem.
So most of the Gurdwaras that
our own Sikh people are coming
in with pot loads of
money to Pakistan,
the Pakistan actually
[inaudible] has been giving
out contracts.
I think the intent is that,
"Oh, we want to help you.
Please go ahead and maintain."
But these people are not
qualified to maintain,
because in East Punjab,
they've destroyed everything.
And I keep telling after these
two works in my brief discussion
that I'm having with the Iraqi
Trust Property Board [phonetic]
in Pakistan so that this
heritage belongs to Pakistan.
My forefathers left it for you.
As much as they say that this
belongs to them and the people
from the Sikh community who
were coming in with pot loads
of money to restore them, it
also belongs to me equally.
And I'm trying to
tell you [inaudible]
that don't give the contracts
unless you've got rules
of engagement, that don't let
this heritage buildings be cut,
and what do they
do, marble and gold,
because these are
the last remains
of Sikh heritage left anywhere
in the world, and
it's in Pakistan.
It's your responsibility
to maintain it.
The question is, "When will
it become our responsibility
to maintain it?"
I don't think we can
restore everything.
The question is, "Can the
Sikh community come together
across the world to say we
will pick up two or three
such monuments, and restore them
in the manner our forefathers
left it, as a last site
of what our generations ahead
can see that, "Here are the two,
three monuments we left
for you in the right way."
Yes; so I think there's
something for us to think.
I think the Pakistan
government will collaborate.
But we need to come
to the right plan.
And this cannot be
done just by Amardeep,
because I'm a researcher,
I'm a writer, I'm a --
I'm getting new thought,
new things out to you all.
The question is, "How do we
rally around it as a cause?"
Moral depictions;
these monuments have moral
depictions that go beyond faith.
And moral depictions
always convey a story.
In the past -- in the
Gurdwaras [inaudible],
I've seen depictions of even
things like Shravan Kumar.
Now, Shravan Kumar may not
look like a Sikh of totally
like a turban-wearing
and so on, so forth.
But organized religion
has got its own space,
but the modern traditions
could cut across faiths.
Because Shravan Kumar is
a beautiful story of a man
of the Indian subcontinent.
The story what is
being said out here is
that when his parents were
very aged, they wanted to go
around on a pilgrimage, and he
offered his shoulder to put them
into a basket and walk
them across the continent
to actually -- subcontinent
to take them to these places
of worship, because
he respected them.
The story is out here of
how to respect your parents.
It's nothing the religion.
And these frescoes
actually found a place.
And therefore, I'm looking
at this monument out here,
which I talked about,
the Banoliber [phonetic],
the first copy of
the [inaudible],
which was written out here.
The beautiful building from
inside, when I look at it,
from outside the frescoes have
no restriction of any faith.
Inside the restrictions
of the faith are
that it's only the Sikh guru's
frescoes which are made.
And in the center when the --
where the worship would happen,
only words are written out
here, words from the Scripture.
Now, to me the message
is that all are welcome,
and therefore there's
no restriction of faith,
and the Sikh gurus are holding
their hand and taking the center
where only the word matters,
only the message of the Grant,
which is the word which matters.
And therefore when I'm looking
at all this, I'm standing
in the Pakistan side in the
village called "Ganda Singh".
This is Ganda Singh Wala.
It's a Sikh name.
And I'm looking at
the other side,
the village on the other side
of the water is Philosport
[phonetic].
"Philosport" is an Islamic
name, "Philos" [phonetic],
and here is Ganda Singh.
The irony is Punjab could
have never been divided.
And as I'm standing and
looking at the irony
of the two villages,
Philosport and Ganda Singh,
a Muslim village on that side
and Ganda Singh out here,
I've seen so many of them.
Kilajivan Singh [phonetic]
in Pakistan and [inaudible]
on the other side in India.
Right; Islamic name
on that side,
the Sikh name on this side.
It reminds me that
for the Punjabis,
it is felt like the left
their jackets in India
and their trousers in Pakistan.
Of course, they can't even
dress up after that, right?
And therefore, when I
went to Jalan Gurdwara,
I've looked at these boards
out there, the Gurdwaras,
and the Gurdwaras
are absolutely empty,
no service has happened
for seven decades.
But yet out here it is written
out here, "[Foreign language]."
The morning prayer of the Sikhs,
which is sung in every temple,
is yet waiting for
that to happen.
And therefore, I'm reminded of
the "Sounds of Silence" of Simon
and Garfunkel, you hear
that "Sound of Silence",
the song tonight, and
it reminds you of this,
sometimes the sounds of silence
can be actually deafening,
because nothing has happened
in these monuments
for seven decades.
And yet, the program
says, "When is it going
to happen; it's waiting as to."
I want to talk about
the uniqueness
of recognizing all human race
as one, because when you look
at the data side
[phonetic] Gurdwara,
what I found is a beautiful
coming together the plurality
or the coming together
of the communities.
A Sikh -- a Pashtuns
Sikh is sitting
on the [inaudible]
reading the Grant.
The descendants -- the Muslim
descendants of Baba Nanak --
[inaudible], the two of
them [inaudible] out here
and Nanak Banti [phonetic]
sitting out here from Sindh.
To me, this was an all
inclusiveness message,
which was plummeted in the Sikh
faith o come together, right?
But today, it has come too hard
that maybe these people
will not get accepted by us.
But in Pakistan,
they are existing.
And this is the beauty
of the coexistence.
And therefore, I want to --
in the [inaudible] of time,
I'm not going to show
the video of this one,
but this is a Muslim
community of descendants
of [inaudible] best
friend, who actually are
yet doing the [inaudible]
inside the data side Gurdwara
for ten minutes every Sunday.
And the interesting thing that
they told me is that the irony
of Partition is such
that my forefathers used
to do [inaudible] at the
Golden Temple, and [inaudible].
And when Partition
happened, we moved the site --
our father moved the site with
the hope that we will go back.
But the Partition
line was so hard
that they could never go back.
And two of the ironies that
we're seeing in these Gurdwaras
out here, but there's
not a single Sikh
to hurt us [phonetic].
I mean, we are seeing the walls
[phonetic] basically out here.
Culture and art; I want
to show this place,
which is pretty much
destroyed and finished
because the communities
are gone.
This is a place which
was of the Udases.
The Nanak Bhanti [phonetic]
tradition was very, very big.
And the Udases tradition, I want
to just make one point out here,
because I've tried to go into
the places of the others,
because these don't
exist in India.
The Udasi tradition places have
all been, again, plastered,
and whitened, and turned
into glittering places,
and there's nothing
of past left.
Now, and Pakistan as
I've gone inside these.
Although it looks like
a pretty bad state,
it's in Pakistan's heritage.
I think the Pakistan government
should maintain this place
[inaudible] beautiful
frescoes inside it.
There's a fresco here I found
of what my forefathers --
today the Western
world is talking
about women's empowerment,
and way back in 1600s,
it shows of women going for
hunt, and men were sitting
and chilling with hawks
sitting in their hands, right?
So that's a women's empowerment,
which was way, way ahead, right?
And looking at these frescoes,
all I can take away is 90%
of these frescoes are about
Sikh traditions, the Sikh gurus,
the Sikh military traditions,
the Sikh stories,
and so, so forth.
And when I look at them, I
say, "You know what, yes,
the Udasi tradition is not
considered to be a part
of the Sikh faith today, but
somehow these people felt
so close to us that they were
drawing only the Sikh traditions
in their art form.
Why would someone draw
the Sikh tradition
if they were not
actually close to us,"
is the question that I ask.
I don't have the
answers to these,
but it's a question I ask.
They believed in us, that's
why they do it, right?
And therefore, I'm just
bringing this to an end
with the last two slides.
Amongst all these emotions,
as close to the [inaudible],
dividing India and Pakistan,
I walked into the remains
of this Gurdwara, made in the
memory of the third Sikh guru.
Most of it is -- all of it has
fallen off [inaudible] land.
Only one section
of it is standing,
and that, too, it's leaning.
I call it as "The
Leaning Tower of Punjab".
And as I'm looking at it, I
walked in and I touched it,
after having photographed it.
And as I touched
it, it spoke to me.
And I want to share with
you what it spoke to me;
because it's very relevant
because it raised a question
for me afterwards in my mind.
It says to me, "Welcome back.
Welcome back.
Where were you for
seven decades?"
And I kept hearing it, and
it says, "Where were you
for seven decades, because when
[inaudible] from Persia came,
massacred your community,
Amachob Dali [phonetic] came,
massacred what you call
as the 'First Holocaust'
and the 'Second Holocaust' in
the Sikh history, what is known
as 'Pella Kalukala' and
'Second Kalukala' [phonetic].
Yet you stayed here.
So what happened in 1947 that
you simply chose to walk away?
Did you not have a moral
responsibility towards us?"
Now, this is the
monument that's asking.
I know the history.
So a lot of time, people start
getting up and telling me,
"Why have you walked away."
I know the history, so let's
not waste time on that, right?
But the fact is the
monument's emotion which says,
"Why did you walk away?"
And as I walked away, I
asked myself this question,
"Was there a solution where
we could have coexisted
on both the sides
of the border?"
I don't know the answer.
But I know that the
Sikhs were 18%
of the greater Punjab's
population.
We were going to be
-- we were a minority,
we had a kingdom,
we had an empire.
We were a minority.
We are still a minority
everywhere in the world,
and if the nation
was being divided,
we would have been a
minority on both the sites.
That wouldn't have changed.
So could there have
been a solution
that we could have coexisted
on both sides of the border?
I don't know the answer, but it
was a very important question
that I still ponder upon.
And I want to end
on a positive note,
because at Vaishali
[phonetic] when I went in,
this old man saw me, and
he gives me a big hug;
and this is the human emotion
that you need to anchor on,
works of monuments, works
of tangible, intangible.
There's enough to read on it and
the human emotions interspersed.
But at the end of the day, I
believe in the human values.
Because as I walked in, he
gives me a big hug and he says
in Punjabi and I've
translated it,
and he says, "[Foreign
language]."
What he's saying is, "By looking
at you today, I'm reminded
by my childhood friend,
[inaudible],"
whom he has not met
for seven decades,
Because the lines divided them.
And as I was coming out from
of Baba [inaudible] mausoleum,
the great Sufi poet, who are not
just the Muslims and the Sufis,
if you are Sikhs, Hindus,
everyone, [inaudible]
and I was coming out this
man limping on the other side
of the road says to me,
"[Foreign language]," "Welcome."
And he comes rushing this side.
This shop is not his, but
he picks up the petals.
And in that moment, a friend
of my took this picture.
And he showers those
petals on me, and he says,
"If I cut my finger, and if I
cut your finger, does blood flow
in yours, and does
milk flow in mine?"
And I want to end here, because
this is about a human story
and this human story
applies to all communities.
I have chosen to study it
from a Sikh lens perspective.
If I'm given a chance to do this
from any other community's
perspective, Hindu or Muslim,
I think the story of
Partition will be the same.
Thank you very much.
I'm happy to take any questions.
I know we've got just now
about ten minutes or so,
so I can take a few
questions if you want.
[ Applause ]
So in asking questions,
again, as Jonathan said,
by request let's not
tell our comments,
because time is little, okay?
If there any questions,
I'm happy to take them.
>> So Amardeep, [inaudible].
>> Amardeep Singh: So I --
>> Sorry, can you
please repeat that?
>> Oh; how many years did
you spend [inaudible]?
>> Amardeep Singh: So
as I said to you --
maybe you missed it in the
beginning, you came late,
I went into Pakistan
in 2014 first.
And by now, it's been three and
a half years that I've spent
in these two publications, which
are these two text publications.
Now, these are available and if
you want, you can actually go
to amazon.com and write for
the books' names or you can go
to lostheritagebook.com and
order there, or if you go
to Rajwant, he's sitting
here, and you can tell him --
he's bringing in some books.
He can actually arrange to
have it -- give it to you.
You can meet Rajwant afterwards.
But to answer to your
question is so these two books
from the research
to the completion
for both the books has taken
me three and a half years
from the time I stepped
into Pakistan in 2014.
But actually, I tell you that
it's a journey of over 30 years,
because over 30 years, I did
not know what I was doing;
I was doing my job and I
was just doing all kinds
of spirituality studying,
and faith studying,
history studying, photography,
writing for magazines.
I think those all
those skills came
in handy the day my
corporate career ended,
not knowingly why it was ending,
I was in a confused state,
but the new door opened.
And I think that's when
now I can rationalize
and say actually God was
preparing me for 30 years.
I think it's a very tough
task to do if you just walk
into the country today and
think you can replicate this,
because a lot of
energies over a period
of time actually come together.
Yes?
>> Okay.
>> Amardeep Singh: Yes.
>> Because three and a
half years is not enough
to do what you did.
You know, so it's -
>> Amardeep Singh: No, it's not.
I'm running at a
[inaudible] pace.
I only know it's taking a
toll on body, on my mind.
I'm hitting a roadblock.
There's a lot of
challenges around.
Each book is six
years' PhD work.
It can -- in an academic
environment,
it takes 12 years to
13 years to do it.
But yet, we got it from three
to three and a half years.
Yes.
>> [Inaudible]; I'm
really touched [inaudible],
then I'm going to
ask you a question.
[Foreign language] and he said,
"How long you have been here?"
[Inaudible].
So I said, "How about you?"
He said, "I just came here."
I said, "And welcome
to the United States."
So he was talking Punjabi,
and I could figure out,
because I'm from Pakistan.
I said, "You are
touched me, you know,
he said that about ten years
back I met a young lady,
who was left as a orphan,
you know, in Pakistan.
Actually, her mother
was left [inaudible].
And the reason I
[inaudible], "That's wonderful."
And then he showed
me his [inaudible].
And I said, "Oh, that's
wonderful," you know.
He said, "I'm half Sikh."
Well, I asked him, you
know, "Very impressed."
So he felt [inaudible]
"Why, because I'm Sikh,"
because she belonged
to a Sikh family.
And he tells me, "That's
why I go to Gurdwara."
And I said, "That's wonderful."
But I didn't ask him
how they both manage,
you know, because [inaudible].
And then he asked me a
question that, "I have a son
who only wants to
marry a Sikh woman."
So I felt -- I wanted to ask
-- and this happened today,
you know, so I want
to ask you --
and you know, in your research
over there, did you meet anybody
who was himself Sikh descendant?
>> Amardeep Singh: How many
do you want me to [inaudible]?
[Laughter] There's an entire
communities living there
who don't -- so there are --
as I said, there are one million
people who are Sikhs themselves
who are sitting there,
who are proud Sikhs,
in their mind they're Sikhs.
There are 14,000 turban-wearing
Sikhs whom we think of as Sikhs,
and whom the Pakistani
government counts as Sikhs.
But the hearts of one
million people are believers
of Sikh faith.
That's the Sikhs themselves.
How many people do
you want me to count?
There are many -- people
have mentioned whom I've met,
had lunch with them,
had stayed with them
who have Sikh backgrounds,
but had to change their faith,
either of choice,
either of the compulsion,
either of the circumstances.
My own distant aunt's story
in the book, "Meeting Moody,"
who was just 20 is there.
My own real aunt's
two sons had lived
as Christians inside
[inaudible] for two years,
because they were
five and six years old
and their parents
were departed from --
were separated from them in
the [inaudible] massacre,
and then they were found after
about three to four years.
My book starts on that story.
There are umpteen number
of instances like this.
The upheaval that happened
was one million people died,
ten million people moved.
The cultures have shifted.
The people from the Indus --
from the Gangetic belt were
thrust into the Indus belt,
and the people of the Indus
belt thrust elsewhere.
It's a hodgepodge
that has happened.
Languages, the issues
that we're talking about,
the people in the Gangetic belt
don't understand the history
and the faiths, how
they intertwined
in this beautiful land of Indus.
We were never separate.
The Hindus, Sikhs, and
Muslims, they were fractured,
hairline fracture but knew how
to live together for centuries.
And that's why poetry
are beautiful things.
Scriptures reflect that, right?
But yet, when partition
happened,
people who were not even knowing
of this culture were thrust
into this land, and therefore
emerged a total confused state
of mind on both sides
of the border.
We have to go back to humanity.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Amardeep Singh: [Laughs] So
the next steps basically,
you know -- okay,
the short answer
to that would be I don't know.
I have no idea.
I am living in a creative
space after my 25 years
of corporate world where I
wish to make five-year plan,
ten-year plan, 20-year plan,
and never achieve them anyway.
And now, I make no plans
and something happens.
Right; so I don't know.
But I am under immense
internal turmoil,
and I think the internal
turmoil should be there,
because if you don't have
the internal turmoil,
the creative space
cannot generate anything.
And Gurbani [phonetic] says this
very well, "[Foreign language],"
"Douk" [phonetic] is "Sadness
becomes your medicine,
the remedy, and happiness
becomes your source
of pulling you down,
your disease," right?
And I think the unhappiness
is not the unhappiness
from the world, but it's the
state of my mind that I grapple
with day in and day out,
because my project seems
to be coming to an end.
And do I go on this
path further?
There are Nanak Panthis who
are waiting to be called,
and to be addressed,
and to be studied.
How do I do it; I don't know.
Can I do it; I don't know.
There is a world which
requires financial commitment.
There's a family that requires
-- I don't know how to do it.
But last time I was thrust into
this by some unknown force,
will it thrust me into it again?
I just need to eat bread
and butter; I don't need
to become a wealthy man.
But what I'm leaving
here I know is the wealth
for the future communities
to come.
>> Thank you Amardeep, thank
[inaudible] organize this.
Do you think the -- what
Sikh has just kind of --
in the middle of
[inaudible], right?
And everything that
you're doing,
everything in the same timeframe
of the last four, five,
ten years there have been
other projects as well going
on related to Sikh, and
preservation, and revival.
Can that -- can the -- some
of the effects of the --
what happened in '47,
can they be reversed?
>> Amardeep Singh: Of course.
>> Since -- okay.
>> Amardeep Singh:
Okay, go ahead.
>> The access can be better
and access to [inaudible] --
>> Amardeep Singh: If you
don't believe in something,
nothing is going to happen.
If I didn't believe that I
could generate a research,
just my own belief,
nothing would have happened.
I think everything
stems from belief.
So we have to believe that
we can change the world
for positivity, right?
Then, things will
start happening.
As far as you saying that
so much is happening around,
yes, a lot is happening.
But if I'm going
to be very myopic
on this subject oSikh
legacy in Pakistan, sorry,
I'm going to ask you, "What else
has happened in seven decades,
other than just maintaining
the [inaudible], going around
and around in circles, whitening
them, putting gold, putting,
you know, money inside it,
giving more money to people
to go and destroy
more of our heritage,
what else has happened?
Nothing. It's taken
you seven decades
to generate anything
on a legacy.
Some Gurdwara books
have been generated,
but it's all Gurdwara centric,
and legacy is not religion.
So I don't think anything
has happened as yet.
Things can happen.
What I think is that what
we're leaving in the forms
of these 1,000 pages is
a dialogue initiator.
It's the foundation of
something on which both
by the Pakistan people, and for
the Sikhs, and for the Hindus,
and for the Muslims that allows
us to come together and say,
"Oh, my God, we have
forgotten this."
I think my work should
inspire a Muslim to get up
and do the same thing
in East Punjab.
I think my work should
inspire a [inaudible] Hindu
for doing the same
thing in Pakistan.
And when we can do it
altogether, it's not for Sikh,
it's for a bigger picture
about all coming together.
But from a Sikh perspective,
I hope these two works become
the foundation of us to get --
build castles on them, but
without having the data,
you cannot do anything.
I'll tell you I met the
Iraqi Trust Property Board
in February this
time with the head
of the Iraqi Trust
Property Board he's looking
at [inaudible] at my
books that I gifted them,
and he's asking a very
interesting question and that --
and therein lies the answer
of hope and what we can do.
He's opening the book and he
says, "Where is this place?"
And I'm looking at
him and I said,
"Some of my forefathers
left it in your custody.
You tell me where is it."
He called this man,
"Get the register.
See if this place is there."
What I'm trying to say is people
do jobs; bureaucrats do jobs.
They are there for three
to four years to do a job.
First year they're
trying to learn,
second year they are
trying to grapple,
third year they are
trying to look
at the next exit plan; next job.
Who's doing the job of
maintaining and doing things?
And then comes to our community
with pot loads of money.
They open the doors for us to
actually go and preserve it.
And the preservation is
not heritage maintenance,
and it's heritage destruction.
So when he's asking a
question, "Where is this place,"
I am happy he's asking
the question,
because now the data
is lying on his table.
And he tells the
man, "Make a trip.
Next fortnight, I want to go
to Sindh and see [inaudible].
I want to see this place."
Whether something happens or no,
what is the momentum we
can build, time will tell.
Can I lead everything;
no I'm one man right now.
Can we come together and do
something, I think we can.
A lot can happen.
I think the intent is there.
The government has the intent.
The question is, "How do
we navigate through this?
How do we not get stuck in
our mud slingings and think
of a bigger picture," because
a lot needs to be done.
>> Jonathan Loar: And
I think we have time
for just one more question.
>> Amardeep Singh: Sure.
I'll take hers.
>> I was curious to hear
what the response has been
when you approached either
[inaudible] in India,
but specifically from the Indian
government and Sikhs living
in India; because I feel
like how we are [inaudible]
or at least my generation were
born and raised in the States.
We -- I'd like to think that
we have a very secular view
of Sikhs.
But we feel like there was
a disconnect between us
and older generations or how
to practiced in India now.
So how has the response been?
>> Amardeep Singh:
Response to what?
>> Response to this project
about that our roots
are in Pakistan.
You know, there's so much that
we, you know, have neglected,
or we haven't been
able to go back to.
So --
>> Amardeep Singh: So I think
response is the same everywhere.
It's got nothing to do with
India, Pakistan, or US, or UK,
whatever Sikh communities,
response is the same.
The struggle for me as an
individual has been the belief
that I have in me that this
needs to be done, and struggling
to do it, to do it, and get
it to a point where it is now,
and now engaging
with communities
to bring them together.
It has not been easy.
But in that process, the
question is maintenance
of the monument is
a far off vision.
In the midterm, I'm
only having dialogues
with the Pakistan government.
I'm having dialogues with
very different people.
But yet we are not able to come
together as a cohesive force.
But I believe somewhere
it has to start.
Because if you start, magnets
will actually pull us together.
But if you are doing
the right thing,
right things will come together.
So as of right now,
these are early days.
We are not able to
pull together to people
to own a monument
and preserve it.
That's number one.
The number two is a
short-term approach is in India,
for instance, I'm
seeing, you know,
you can afford these books.
These books are not easy to do.
You have to give
up huge amounts;
you have to do research
costs, you have to throw money
to get the data out inside.
You physically go and do it.
And then printing the
publication gets expensive
in India, for the
common man in India.
For Pakistan, it gets expensive.
My vision is you can
afford it in these worlds
because your purchasing
power is much bigger.
But in India, it
always gets questioned,
"Why are the books
so expensive?"
They are seeing it as a book,
they're not seeing the
experience and the things
that have gone behind it.
And I'm telling this
about your own heritage.
When are you going to own it?
They are not even wanting --
an organization in India
has not even supported me
to my simple program
that I'm saying,
"Help me put these books
inside the libraries
of Sikh institutions inside."
It's been three years now; not a
single organization in India --
in Punjab has come forward to
say, "We will take 200 books
to put them inside the
schools and colleges."
Because the next
generation needs to see it.
They were not seen
for seven decades.
That's the kind of
blankness that you see, right?
So that's the big
issue out here.
I'm saying why should the
Pakistanis not have these books?
Because I get every month
five to six people asking me
in Pakistan -- from Pakistan, "I
want to do a PhD work on this.
I will look at the Sikh murals.
I want to see it --
understand some Sikh theology,
Sikh architecture."
And I'm believing that these
books need to be put out there.
You know what, it's
a big problem
to get these books inside
the institutions there,
because from India you have to
move a huge amounts of books.
How can we enable this
through a partnership
with the Pakistan government,
and who will support this?
If I'm going to expect that each
individual organization is going
to actually bring in a
book, it may not happen.
[Inaudible] Sikh man who
says, "You know what,
I'm going to sponsor
a hundred books
for your project and
get them inside."
I'm struggling to get that.
So it is a struggle;
it's not easy.
And the last thing what
I'm saying is when I look
at Nanak Panthis sitting there,
let's talk about where is
Amardeep in all of this?
Amardeep's fluent
in [inaudible];
I have the ability to do that.
I've done two publications
in a very short time.
Do I want to study in Nanak
Panthis and understand
and document them for
our next generations?
It's a project that
needs to be done.
Am I getting support?
I'm really hitting
a head block --
a roadblock; I don't know
where to go now from here,
because I'm not associated
with an institution.
I don't have grants with me.
I'm just doing it on my own.
So all I'm trying to tell you
is it's a challenging task.
But I believe if you
do the things right,
if we lay the foundation
on this,
someone is going to
build the castle.
Will it be me who will
build it, I don't know.
But someone is going
to build it for sure.
>> Jonathan Loar: And
I think on that note
that brings our great
lecture for today to a close.
It's an incredible journey
on an important topic,
and a very powerful presentation
that we have the
honor to hear today.
>> Amardeep Singh: Thank you.
>> Jonathan Loar: So
thank you very much
for coming, Amardeep Singh.
Let's give him [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.